après les enquêteurs la parole est
désormais aux victimes dans le procès
des attentats du 13 novembre pendant
quatre semaines quelques 300 personnes
vont venir témoigner à la barre le
président de la cour d'assises spéciale
a prévu d'entendre une quinzaine d'entre
eux chaque jour notre reporter katia
technique suit pour nous les audiences
les parties civiles du stade de france
ont parlé des gendarmes solide et
militaires aguerris mais très éprouvée
qui s'écroule à la barre quasiment tous
victime de stress post traumatique le
premier est un ancien major de la garde
républicaine qui présente sur les lieux
de la déflagration parle d'un homme
appuyé sur le sol qu'il regardait mais
il était mort il s'agit de manuel diaz
décédé dans cet attentat le major évoque
avec la voix qui tremble à ce moment le
moment le plus terrible de sa carrière
un ancien chauffeur de la garde
républicaine lui évoque les morceaux de
chair le sang partout l'odeur de la
chair brûlée il est depuis sous
traitement suivi par une psychologue il
a passé un mois et demi en hôpital
psychiatrique et il dénonce le problème
post traumatique des blessés à
l'intérieur le fait que les terroristes
ont aussi détruit des familles entières
ont l'écoutent j'étais sur place
à savoir que le premier kamikaze quand
il va exploser il va exploser à 25,26 si
mes camarades ici c'est moi on n'est pas
en fin de compte derrière un camion eh
bien on est touché physiquement
il n'y a pas que le premier
à kamikazes il ya aussi je dirais à
deuxième kamikaze qui va se faire
exploser devant nous
alors là aussi et elle a vu ya l'odeur
et elle s'en est à du corps partout des
trucs qui voit là et quand vous rentrez
vous vous rentrez de service que deux
heures après vous repartez encore en
service parce que cette nuit là c'est
une nuit de folie sur pareil voilà et
bien vous pouvez pas rester insensible
c'est dur c'est très dur tous les jours
c'est dur et vous essayez pour accrocher
à tout et à n'importe quoi mais ça il
faut faut vraiment le tribunal auprès de
comptes conscience il faut ils font voeu
compte que que que le tribunal prenne
conscience qu'il n'y a pas eu que les
victimes
pas eu les blessés pas les morts non
plus il faut savoir que ça a touché tout
le monde les familles ont explosé elles
ont explosé parce qu'elles n'ont pas pu
supporter le système un adjoint
gendarmerie très ému a expliqué que le
moindre bruit l'inquiéter il a des
symptômes post traumatiques lui aussi je
ne sais pas si ce sera fini un jour
remarque-t-il et il a critiqué
l'ignorance de sa hiérarchie son manque
de reconnaissance d'ailleurs un manque
de reconnaissance longuement dénoncé par
leur chef d'escadron qui a la voix qui
tremble lui aussi il parle de sa
sidération de sa pas nier qu'il est très
émue et ses 13 hommes ont vécu des
désastres intérieur des stress très
important et le chef a dû batailler pour
obtenir des aides qui ont été
systématiquement refusées donc des
séquelles psychologiques très importante
peu dead pour ces primes aux
intervenants des témoignages très
poignant